J: Hey guys
PJ: Hey Janet!
J: It's team Korra here
D: Hey hey hey!
J: We just wanted to thank you guys so much for sticking with us these last four seasons, it's been so amazing
PJ: We love you
J: We love you so much, we love Nickelodeon so much for giving us a chance to make the show, and of course the show would not exist...
PJ: Our idols
J: ...without the brilliant minds of Mike and Bryan, we love you guys so much
PJ: Thank you guys for letting us do this
J: You know one of the great things about what Mike and Byan do at Comic Cons, is that they show you alot of behind the scenes stuff on the animation side...
What we felt like what we wanted to do is show you what it's like for us as actors to prepare, so we shot some footage of us getting ready and we wanted to share it with you, since this may be our last con...
thank you so much, we love you.
D: This is a day in the life, thank you!
PJ: I love you guys so much, let's do this!
D:Do you really love me?
PJ: Leave it in the booth!
J: Water... water
PJ: I love you!
D: Okay, okay
PJ: Leave it in the booth!
PJ: Opal ... Opal ... Opal
D: One ... Two ... Three
All: Korra!
J: Earth              PJ: Ahumama
All: (continuation) Korra!
J:Earth                PJ:Ahumama
All:(Continuation) Korra!
*Legend of Korra music theme tune begins to play
J: Open!
J:Ow, well that was ... er
PJ: Alright...
PJ: K...K...o...oo..r.. ra ... K...K...o...oo...r..ra
*eerie music in background.                                           All (chant): Bryke be with us, Bryke be with us, Bryke be with us.
J: K...K...o...ooo...r...rra
*eerie music in background.   All (chant):Bryke give us strength, Bryke give us strength, Bryke give us strength.
J & PJ: K...k...o...oo...r..ra
D: This will be mine.
*dramatic music, D silently mouths:all mine
J&PJ: K...k...o...oo...r..ra ... ka...ka
D: Is that a duck?  *dramatic music
J: This is ridiculous I should not have to do this myself! Makeup!
PJ: Janet, we're not on camera
J: Okay but I just need to make sure that you know, I...
PJ: No, no, no. It's been four years, we're not on camera.
PJ: Alright you know what I just need one more thing to get into it, a little bit, here we go, hold on, give me like half an hour.
J: M....m....mm
D: People do love me, people do love me, people do...
PJ: I don't know how *mumbles* eat so much, noone is going to eat this much
PJ: Hey what are you doing man?
D: Well you know, got to stay in good with Nickelodeon, so got to keep it clean around here.
D: You know we're coming to an end here - another job.  PJ: No, I know
PJ: It goes all the way down, it just goes all the way in, and all the way down
PJ: Hey what are you doing man?
D: Er... you know we're coming to an end here, I'm trying show Nickelodeon my values.
PJ: Oh noo noo *mumbles
D:Oh hey Janet, did you need some headphones?
J:Oh sure I got it
D:Oh thanks, did you? okay. I was just seeing if you needed some for yourself...
J:Sure
PJ: Kids choice award you're mine, kids choice award you're mine, I'm not going to let David get you. Janet can have you, because she's really nice because she really cares about kids.
J: Thanks     PJ: Oh hey honey, how are you?
PJ: How's your day going?    J:Great    PJ: Cool...
PJ:Janet has alot of crying scenes here today, what do you think she is going to do to get ready?
D:Hah! You know Janet, she can cry on queue
J:and so the boy cut down her trunk and made a boat and sailed away, and the tree was happy.
J:But not really..... okay I'm good... we can record!
J:Come on Pabu
J: I love them so much
PJ & D:ssshh sssh
PJ: We're right here, we're right here
J:I know
J:I love them so much!
PJ & D:No, no no, sssh..j...j...janet